muchos menos una familia de clase media para exhibirlas en su casa.
Esa sala tenía que mantenerse perfecta.
Pero todos los días me arriesgaba a desordenar esa sala perfecta
solo para ver ese libro.
En la cubierta había una mujer llamada Septima Clark.
Tenía un perfil perfecto, con la cara levantada hacia el cielo.
Llevaba unas trenzas entrecanas
perfectamente hechas en cada costado de la cabeza,
y de su piel oscura irradiaba orgullo y sabiduría.
Septima Clark fue activista y educadora,
una mujer a quien al final seguiría de ejemplo en mi propia carrera.
Pero más que todas las palabras que ella pudo haber dicho,
ese retrato de Septima Clark en particular me hizo saber lo que es la confianza,
incluso antes de conocer la palabra.
Puede sonar elemental,
pero la confianza es algo cuya importancia subestimamos.
La consideramos como algo deseable, y no como algo obligatorio.
Valoramos más el conocimiento y los recursos
que esa habilidad que juzgamos blanda, que es la confianza.
En muchos sentidos, tenemos más conocimiento y más recursos ahora
que en cualquier otro momento de la historia
y, aun así, siguen persistiendo la injusticia y la adversidad.
Si todo lo que necesitáramos fueran conocimientos y recursos,
ya no estaríamos aquí.
Y creo que la confianza es una de las principales cosas
que hacen falta en la ecuación.
Estoy enteramente obsesionada con la confianza.
Ha sido el viaje más importante de mi vida;
un viaje que, para ser sincera, sigo haciendo.
La confianza es la chispa necesaria para emprender lo que sea.
La confianza es la diferencia entre sentirse inspirado
y empezar realmente algo,
entre intentar algo y hacerlo hasta el final.
La confianza nos permite continuar aunque fallemos.
El nombre de ese libro sobre la mesa se titulaba 'I Dream a World',
y hoy sueño con un mundo donde la confianza revolucionara
nos permita hacer realidad nuestros sueños más ambiciosos.
Esa era la clase de mundo que quería crear en mi clase
cuando era docente,
como un mundo de imaginación pura al estilo de Willy Wonka,
pero mediante la docencia.
Todos mis estudiantes eran negros o morenos.
Todos pertenecían a entornos de bajos ingresos.
Algunos eran inmigrantes, otros discapacitados,
pero todos eran los últimos en ser alentados para desarrollar su confianza.
Por eso era tan importante que mi clase fuese un lugar
para que mis estudiantes pudieran fortalecer el músculo de la confianza,
pudieran aprender a enfrentar el día a día con la confianza necesaria
para reconstruir el mundo según sus propios sueños.
Porque ¿para qué sirven las competencias académicas
si no se tiene la confianza de usarlas para salir y cambiar el mundo?
Ahora es cuando debería contarles de dos alumnas, Jamal y Regina.
He cambiado sus nombres, pero sus historias siguen siendo las mismas.
Jamal era brillante, pero distraído.
Se retorcía en la silla durante trabajos individuales,
y nunca se quedaba quieto por más de tres o cuatro minutos.
Estudiantes así pueden desconcertar a maestros nuevos
porque no saben cómo ayudar a jóvenes como él.
Yo fui al grano.
Llegué a un arreglo con Jamal:
si se concentraba en las tareas
podía hacerlas en cualquier lugar del aula,
en la alfombra, detrás de mi escritorio,
incluso en el casillero de la clase, que resultó ser su lugar preferido.
La actividad que menos le gustaba era escribir,
y nunca quería leer en voz alta lo que había escrito en clase,
pero seguíamos progresando.
Un día decidí armar un simulacro de las elecciones presidenciales del 2008
en mi clase.
Mis alumnos de tercer grado tenían que investigar y hacer un discurso
para su candidato electo:
Barack Obama, Hillary Clinton o John McCain.
Era obvio quiénes serían los favoritos,
pero un estudiante eligió a John McCain.
Fue Jamal.
Jamal finalmente decidió leer en voz alta algo que había escrito para la clase
y, por supuesto, nos asombró a todos con su brillantez.
Al igual que el papá de Jamal, John McCain era un veterano,
y así como el papá protegió a Jamal,
él creía que John McCain protegería a todo el país.
Y no era mi candidato preferido, pero no importaba,
porque toda la clase estalló en aplausos,
y ovacionó de pie a nuestro valiente amigo Jamal,
quien finalmente se mostró con la mayor confianza
por primera vez ese año.
Y luego estaba Regina.
Regina era igual de brillante, aunque activa.
Inevitablemente terminaba su tarea antes que el resto
y luego se dedicaba a distraer a otros alumnos.
(Risas)
Caminaba, hablaba,
pasaba esas notas que a ellos les gusta y a los profes no.
Seguro Uds. lo hicieron.
(Risas)
Pese a mis altas expectativas con la clase,
muchas veces recurría a mis instintos más bajos
y prefería la obediencia a la confianza.
Regina era un fallo en el sistema que yo había concebido.
Una buena profesora puede corregir el mal comportamiento
y seguir siendo un ídolo para el alumno.
Pero, un día en particular,
simplemente elegí el control.
Perdí los estribos,
y mi actitud no le comunicó a Regina
que ella era una distracción para los demás.
Le comunicó a Regina que ella misma era una distracción.
Vi cómo se apagaba la luz en sus ojos,
y esa luz era la que daba alegría a nuestra clase.
Yo la había apagado.
Toda la clase se volvió irritable,
y no nos recuperamos por el resto del día.
Pienso seguido en ese día
y, literalmente, recé por que el daño no fuera irreversible,
porque sé, como una mujer que fue una niña como Regina,
que pude haber empezado el proceso de destruirle la confianza en sí misma
para siempre.
La falta de confianza nos echa para abajo desde el fondo
y nos pesa desde la cima,
aplastándonos con una avalancha de "no puedo", "no sucederá" e "imposible".
Sin confianza, nos estancamos,
y cuando nos estancamos, no podemos siquiera empezar.
En vez de atascarnos con posibles obstáculos,
la confianza nos invita a actuar con seguridad.
Todos funcionamos de forma distinta cuando tenemos la certeza de ganar
y no tan solo la esperanza de ganar.
Ahora bien, puede ser útil revisar esto.
Si no tienes suficiente confianza,
puede que necesites reconsiderar tus metas.
Si tienes demasiada confianza,
puede que tus metas no sean reales.
No a todo el mundo le falta confianza.
En esta sociedad,
hacemos que a algunas personas les sea más fácil tomar confianza
porque encajan en nuestro arquetipo preferido de liderazgo.
Recompensamos la confianza de algunas personas
y castigamos la confianza de otras,
mientras que muchísimas personas
andan por la vida sin sentir la más mínima confianza.
Para algunos de nosotros,
la confianza es una decisión revolucionaria,
y nos causaría una pena enorme
ver que nuestras mejores ideas no se hacen realidad
y nuestros sueños más brillantes no se cumplen
solo porque nos faltó el motor de la confianza.
Es un riesgo que no estoy dispuesta a correr.
¿Cómo descifrar el código de la confianza?
En mi opinión, hacen falta al menos tres cosas:
permiso, comunidad y curiosidad.
El permiso crea confianza,
la comunidad la desarrolla
y la curiosidad la afirma.
Tenemos un dicho en educación:
"No puedes ser lo que no ves".
Cuando era una niña, no podía mostrar confianza
hasta que alguien me lo enseñó.
Mi familia solía hacer todo en familia,
incluyendo cosas mundanas como comprar un auto nuevo,
y cada vez que lo hacíamos,
veía a mis padres ejecutar la misma acción:
entrábamos al concesionario,
y mi papá se sentaba
mientras mi mamá hacía la compra.
Cuando mi mamá encontraba un auto que le gustaba,
entraban a hablar con el concesionario
e, inevitablemente, cada vez que el concesionario desviaba su atención,
se dirigía a hablar con mi papá,
dando por sentado que él manejaba los gastos
y, por ende, las negociaciones.
"Reverendo Packnett", decían, "¿cómo lo convenceremos a comprar hoy este auto?".
Mi papá siempre respondía de la misma manera.
Señalaba lenta y silenciosamente a mi madre
y se ponía las manos de vuelta sobre el regazo.
Debió haber sido toda una conmoción hacer negocios con una mujer negra en los 80,
pero, como fuere,
yo veía cómo mi madre negociaba con esos concesionarios
hasta que básicamente les daban el auto gratis.
(Risas)
Ella nunca sonreía.
Nunca tenía miedo de darse la vuelta y marcharse.
Sé que mi mamá solo pensaba en cerrar un buen trato por un minivan,
pero lo que en realidad estaba haciendo
era darme permiso para desafiar las expectativas
y mostrar confianza en mis habilidades sin importar quién dude de mí.
La confianza necesita del permiso para existir
y la comunidad es el lugar más seguro para intentarlo.
Viajé este año a Kenia para aprender sobre el empoderamiento
en las mujeres masáis.
Ahí conocí a un grupo de mujeres jóvenes llamado "Team Lioness",
que era de los primeros grupos de guardabosques femeninas.
Estas ochos mujeres valientes estaban haciendo historia
siendo apenas adolescentes,
y le pregunté a Purity, la guardabosque más locuaz del grupo:
"¿Alguna vez sientes miedo?".
Les juro que quiero hacerme un tatuaje en todo mi cuerpo con su respuesta.
Ella dijo: "Por supuesto que sí,
pero luego miro a mis hermanas.
Ellas me recuerdan que seremos mejores que esos hombres
y que no fracasaremos".
La confianza de Purity para perseguir leones y atrapar cazadores furtivos
no venía de sus aptitudes deportivas ni de su fe.
Su confianza estaba basada en su hermandad,
en su comunidad.
Lo que estaba diciendo era que, si alguna vez llego a dudar,
necesito que estén ahí,
para recuperar mi esperanza y reconstruir mi seguridad.
Puedo encontrar mi confianza en comunidad
y la curiosidad la puede consolidar.
A inicios de mi carrera, dirigí un gran evento
que no salió exactamente como esperaba.
Les estoy mintiendo. Salió horrible.
Y cuando le informé sobre el evento a mi gerenta,
sabía que ella empezaría a nombrar
todos los errores que haya cometido
quizás desde que nací.
En vez de eso, empezó con una pregunta:
"¿Cuál era tu intención?".
Quedé sorprendida, pero aliviada.
Ella sabía que yo ya estaba siendo dura conmigo misma
y esa pregunta me invitó a aprender de mis propios errores
en lugar de dañar mi confianza ya resquebrajada.
La curiosidad invita a las personas a estar a cargo de su propio aprendizaje.
Ese intercambio me ayudó a asumir mi siguiente proyecto
con expectativas de éxito.
Permiso, comunidad, curiosidad;
cosas que necesitaremos para fomentar la confianza,
para resolver nuestros mayores desafíos
y para construir el mundo que soñamos.
Un mundo donde no haya desigualdades y donde la justicia realmente exista.
Un mundo donde podamos ser libres, tanto por dentro como por fuera,
porque sabemos que nadie es libre hasta que todos lo somos.
Un mundo que no esté intimidado por la confianza
cuando se manifiesta en una mujer,
o en una piel oscura,
o en cualquier otro de nuestros arquetipos preferidos de liderazgo.
Un mundo que sepa que esa clase de confianza
es exactamente la llave que necesitamos para abrir puertas al futuro que deseamos.
Tengo la confianza suficiente para creer que ese mundo
sin duda se convertirá en realidad,
y que seremos nosotros quienes lo harán posible.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)